♪♪
Hello you! I'm so glad you're
here.
Jack:
Welcome to the town of
Clover Grove.
-Hello Jack.
Jack:
Where one act of kindness...
Surprise!
Jack:
...can grow and grow.
To help you finish your big
game.
Jack:
And start a chain of many
more.
Come on, we can play the game
with Cooper.
(Cheering)
Welcome to the Hummingbird Cafe.
♪Try a little act of kindness♪
I've never been in a bus before.
I'm imagining.
(Beep, beep)
Hello, Bus.
♪Show a stranger some
politeness♪
You want to sit next to me?
We can be bus buddies.
♪Watch the little moment grow
and grow♪
♪♪
That looks so great, Hugo.
Thanks! And thank you, Crayons.
Ohh, thank you.
Ho-ho, you got it, Hugo.
♪Try a little act of kindness♪
♪♪
Hello, you.